hey my buddy case rosso has the greatest
ikea story you'll ever hear
he told it during the panel on one of my
live shows check it out
buddy tell the ikea story let me get the
[ __ ] out of here all right
i was 16 years old this job paid eight
dollars and fifty cents an hour
and i got put on returns my like second
day there
uh this guy returned a lamp and the lamp
was a dollar ninety nine
and i put in the supply code where it
says the amount returned so i put in he
returned 1079 lamps for 1.99
and he got 11 000 credited back on his
credit card
i get up i go tell my boss what happened
he's like just figure it out
i'm 16 i go all right i hit i hit
finish transaction i go in my head i'm
like i'm young i go to my into my boss i
go
hey are you sure [ __ ] left i was
alone i was alone out there
ikea has a computer system that's like
that old school black
and green screen works great if you work
in a [ __ ]
uh warehouse or whatever right there's
eight registers in ikea every time you
return something
a sticker prints out for the item after
five stickers it gets sent to the next
register i shut down the returns
department in ikea
for eight hours while 1079 stickers
printed out
and everyone left but me
bro i was there with like 200 families
and i'm sitting there with 16 years old
and [ __ ] got like beds like i
want a divorce
they're looking at me like it's him and
i'm like i gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here i don't know what's happening
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] wild
bro it's hilarious because i just left i
was like all right
yo no one even said anything to me i was
like all right well that my shift is
over
i just walked out and went home like i
didn't even talk to anybody
i obviously got fired but they fired me
like an adult which was ridiculous
i was 16 years old i got a letter it was
paul
and deb deb's a sweetheart paul is
a giant black man that went to the army
he had uh each one of his thighs was as
big as both of my legs together
you'll find out why i mentioned he was
black in a second um
they they slid a letter across to me and
it was like hey we think you're great
and you have a lot of great yeah i said
all this [ __ ] they were like but at
this time we don't think we should
continue our employment here at ikea
and i got up and i was like oh okay and
then paul goes you're not upset
even a little bit this doesn't bother
you you cost his company 65 thousand
dollars
and i said i said you know i've been
working here two days you should pay me
a thousand when i applied we could have
called it even
and i saw a black man get red and decide
not to hit a child it was crazy he
grabbed the [ __ ]
back of the chair like this and looked
at me and he flexed it
and he went beat red and i could just
see he was like i want to [ __ ] hit
this kid
so bad right now anyway uh i have
friends that work there
and they did great and they worked there
for many years and they told me
if you go to apply to kia in hicksville
long island there is a handbook of what
not to do and my stickers are in that
handbag
i am immortal out of here thank you
what's up guys thanks for watching the
video if you're a fan just hit subscribe
stop hating what are you waiting for
that way you'll get updated whenever i
put up new videos and we got a lot
coming after warranty
[Music]